um but it still doesn't mean that men
like that's it and you see all these
like male podcasts at the moment who are
like if my wife gets pregnant and
doesn't lose the weight i might be
[ __ ] kidding me that's your wife and
she's gonna have your kid i think
i agree that like i agree with the men
yeah i think i i agree look at i'm sorry
i'm sorry look at it
i'm not sorry
yeah i'm sorry there we go
i understand i think of a girl okay if
she gains 10 20 pounds but if you get in
like 50 75 pounds after you get or
before some girls do it before yeah yeah
he has a right to leave you like but
then does the woman have the same rights
yes okay good cool cool yes women women
women leave all the time because of
financial reasons though
finance not fat nothing
i know but the difference is those are
both of things that you have within your
control does that make sense
i mean
finance is a bit more difficult because
obviously it depends on what job you get
well yeah so arguably if a woman leaves
a man for financial that's probably
harsher than a man leaving her for
weight because it's harder to get good
finances than it is to lose weight
yeah that's uh no i i can't disagree
with that funny my my ex used to ask me
all the time not saying that depends if
she's a mother my children i think i
would i wouldn't leave because i think
that's because you know it's about the
kids but i think my ex would ask me all
the time you know she was a dancer in
you know very good shape she was like oh
if i got like really really like obese
would you still love me i was like i
still love you but we just be friends
if i stayed in the same shape
if i kept the high standards like
because obviously if a girl is attracted
to me not because if part of her
attraction to me is because of my
physical
appearance or prowess or whatever
and then if i lose that i can't then get
pissed off if she loses attraction to me
if that was one of the major key factors
does that make sense or do you think
that's really bad
um
it's yeah it's
situational it's really yeah i
i can't ever argue that's the situation
that's his situation yeah that's your
situation so do you think in that
situation
he's wrong um
i would never like to tell someone
they're wrong i would never like them
but we're asking your opinion so now you
if you think it's wrong the floor is
yours go ahead
um well then i think it comes down to
compassibility so if you're the type of
person that's like well i'm gonna really
care about my physique in xyz and
they're like well i'm not then it's like
you're very much not compatible and then
i don't think she's saying she has to
have abs everything oh no yeah
and i'm saying he's just saying don't be
obese yeah yeah but then it's like if
you care
a lot about someone's physicality and
they don't care a lot about their
physical you don't think everyone cares
about physicality a blind person doesn't
a blind person does not why do you look
for the exception to every rule because
you know when you notice when you know
what i'm talking about in general no but
kindness and obviously like then there
are people who can't help being
paralyzed or like and so that's like i
had a boyfriend who once was like um
let's be real if i was in a car accident
and you had to care for me the rest of
my life i couldn't sleep with you guys
paraplegic i was like yeah of course i'd
stay with you but i know that there's
people who like genuinely would be like
oh i don't know if i could do that i
actually don't know if if you weren't
hot if i had to care for you if i
couldn't sleep with you there are people
who would be like and it doesn't make
them laugh did you know did you know
that women leave men 80 of the time and
if they're college educated it's 90 so
if you get divorced it's 80 of the time
like the woman leaves and one of the
number one predictors of a divorce is
actually if the woman out earns the man
oh i love that i actually love that i
can't lie actually you love that you
don't think that's kind of shitty no i'm
like girl you you go get that you go get
a man like yeah you go get that like
really yeah like why is there like a
lack of empathy for ben it's not lack of
empathy but there is because like
they're they're breaking up a family a
lifelong commitment in a home and your
your reaction is you go like go get that
go get the bag sister like i'm so happy
for you when that's actually a really
like that's a sad situation like your
wife is leaving you but then we could
argue that if a mom wanted it enough and
wanted to be enough then we could argue
that but he could be enough but he he
can't because he's she out earned him
like that's that's what i'm saying so
that's okay but if it was possible for
her why isn't it possible him for him
if she could do it and make that money
why couldn't he i think there are times
where you make less money like yeah my
dad's in the top half a percent of
earners there there were times where he
was barely making any money yeah and my
mom stayed because she's a loyal [ __ ]
and so i'm not going to say eugosis when
you leave a lifelong commitment and a
family you made because you're you out
earned your husband and then it depends
on if your priority is money if your
priority is right so what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that's selfish and
that's wrong
and like yeah and you're saying eugosis
and i say i have a lot of empathy for
the men that go through that yeah and so
i just don't understand this like like
why do we immediately take the woman's
side
oh not immediately no and
but right there you did because i gave
you some stats and some numbers and you
like that was and it's okay i think it's
normal actually i think it's like part
of a gynocentric social order yeah
because like we always like our our as a
society we always take the woman's side
like well i don't know why that is yeah
i think i think well from my own bias
that's it i would i'm not necessarily i
would actually this is the irony is i
would actually like a partner that out
earns me i would actually like a man i
would like i'm gonna fully be like i
would like a man almost most girls do i
would like a man i would like a man to
out earn me and take care of me however
i love the idea of being
financially independent and being
successful
and
this is where it's really like uh well
because you know it doesn't work if i
was with a man that was like
i feel bad that you out earned me
i probably wouldn't respect him i can't
really explain why but then i'm also
like i i want to be able to be like i
want i'd like a man that's like i
respect the fact that at some point you
may out earn me and i'll be comfortable
with it but then i'm like
i would like a man to out earn me and
that is yeah yeah but that's that's the
thing like actions have consequences
yeah right so i think feminism often
tells women we can have everything we
can make a lot of money and have you you
can't like you can't you can make a lot
of money you can have the family and you
can have a husband that out earns you
and actually you know what like my mom
actually did have everything but
everything comes with a cost and people
don't understand what the cost i think
it's the bare minimum like where women
can
there's a bare minimum where you can
actually get everything you want and it
works out but i think but it's it's the
exception
yeah 100
um just play devil's advocate because
that's my favorite things to do if you
haven't noticed
um
so you just said that you would like a
man who earns more than you and who can
take care of you which
most women
prefer as well
do you not think that's very
anti-feminist of you
no 100 100 and i know that comes from
um
it comes from quote unquote daddy issues
it comes from growing from poverty and
it comes from also being i think it's
just natural part of being a woman
i can only pick my own experience yeah
yeah so for you do you not think that
desire to have a man who can take care
of you is just part of being a woman for
you
no because i'm not straight
so
yeah
do you do you i have a question are you
are you bi i'm pansexual
what is it i don't know what that means
um so pansexual means that you are open
to the possibility of being attracted to
anyone regardless of sex gender you you
did just say you wanted a man though
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay if if it
was a man that's it if it was a woman if
it was someone who was transgender it
might be different okay question why
because
because i have a couple of friends who
are bi who date men and women and they
apply a different standard for men than
they do for men why is that
um
because if it's about the person it's
not about the gender it's about the
person
why would you why do you why do you
apply different standards for a man and
i would argue maybe because i'm a man
but i argue the standards you have for
men are a lot higher than the standards
you would have for a woman why why do
you have why do you apply different
standards depending on the gender when
arguably if you